I guess the apple don't fall fall from
the tree cuz I've been looking at you so
long now I only see me I want to throw
the Apple into the sky feels like you
never understand me so I just want to
drive to the airport the aort
apple
apple I guess the Apple could turn
yellow green and there different nuances
to you and to me I want to grow the
Apple keep all the seats but I can't
help it so angry you don't listen to the
aort the aort the
aort the airport the airport
[Music]
I'm going to drive going to drive all
night I'm going to drive going to drive
all night I think the app right to the
from the things down from all the
before I SP the down symmetrical L want
find kind scary
[Music]
way you go when you feeling alone when
you feeling alone
yeah I know where you go when you're
feeling alone when you feel alone
he
[Music]
hey friends I hope you enjoyed that flow
session as much as I enjoyed creating it
I love rocking out Charlie XCX and if
you like rocking out to sets of LED
like these orb poy Pros that I was using
in the video you can get a discount on a
set of these when you use the promo code
Drex factor with a zero instead of an O
over at ultra.com once again that is
Drex factor with a zero instead of an o
that will get you 10% off your purchase
so go pick up a set of these and uh also
helps out the channel so everybody wins
thanks so much to ultra PO for
sponsoring this video and giving me a
reason to go out and flow every month uh
speaking of thank yous thank yous are
also owed to the Friends of the channel
big thanks to dark monk flow fests flow
toys Pyar light toys and Ultra poy for
helping to make the videos on this
channel possible you can learn more
about all these awesome companies and
the work that they're doing to support
flow artists like yourself by checking
out the links that I've got down in the
description of this video finally uh
this video and all the videos on this
channel would not be possible were it
not for my amazing supporters on patreon
in particular I'd love to give a shout
out to my flow patrons who are listed on
screen right now thank you all so much
for supporting my channel and my work
and if you out there watching are not
currently supporter but you'd like to
become one you can do that by heading
over to my patreon at patreon.com
drexfactor Po and signing up there you
can get access to a whole host of
awesome rewards but better than that
you'll be helping me out in my mission
to bring po spinning and flow Arts to
the whole wide world so go check that
out please and thank you if you're
hungry for more flow sessions like the
one you just watched I will go ahead and
include a link to a playlist of those
videos down in the description as well
as up on screen thank you so much for
watching make sure to get out and flow
yourselves today and I'll see you with a
new video real soon peace